well you remember last year there was
this big controversy over a nascar
driver named bubba wallace the
controversy occurred because there was a
suggestion that bubba wallace's
garage had been fixed with a news that
somebody had sort of stopped by and then
put a noose on the on bubba wallace's
garage in order to threaten
bubba wallace and as it turns out that
was just a bunch of crap like the fbi
came and investigated and it wasn't true
it turns out that it was just a hand
pull because it turns out that when
you're pulling a garage closed you need
to hold on to a thing and very often
somebody will tie like a loop and you'll
use that loop to pull down the garage
now to be fair to bubba wallace the loop
looked kind of like a noose but like a
tiny news because it wouldn't have fit a
human head it was like for your hand but
this was a major national story and you
had the entire nascar community rallying
behind bubba wallace and everybody
talking about
racism it was a big thing because nascar
is filled with you know those those
white people with their whiteness and
being white and they're from the south
and as we all know the south is filled
with southerners who are from the south
and also hate black people because
they're from the south in slavery 160 70
years ago and all that so it turns out
it was all not true
that again it was a it was just a pulley
on a it was a pull
rope on a garage
and you know who debunked this was espn
so espn's an investigation and espn
reported at the time that the whole
thing
really had nothing to do with racism at
all and that in fact we had we had
created an entire narrative around
nonsense
because again it was not true
okay and bubba wallace has continued to
play the race game
so
he actually tweeted just a couple of
weeks ago about the not guilty verdict
in the kyle rittenhouse trial
he tweeted ha let the boy be black and
it would have been life hell he would
have had his life taken before the bs
trial sad right so bubba wallace is a
far-left racial activist
who was not victimized by a hate crime
and espn knows that he was not
victimized by a hate crime and yet espn
did an entire big story on
bubba wallace
and a hate crime that didn't occur
because diversity or priorities or
something here is uh here's a little bit
of espn's report on bubba wallace and
the hate crime that was not but again
it's with hero overtones and and backlit
shots and swelling music the whole thing
i just wanted to stand with him during
the national anthem to show my support
for him and was appalled by
what i had learned
and then as drivers got involved i think
crew members team managers team owners
it really started to snowball within a
very short period of time
the most and the music incredible
non-competitive moment in sports i'd
ever seen
because they all they all walked around
his car now again listen to that moment
and swelling we all did as we were
walking oh man we all sided with bubba
wallace and we all guided his car get
out of the car
i looked back
and i was like holy sh it's a whole
garage
the whole garage
that's when i lost it
okay so pause it for just one second it
didn't happen okay it wasn't a noose now
if this was a story about how america
hates racism
that that'd be fine because america does
hate racism
in fact america hates racism so much
that if somebody declares that a hate
crime has happened and it didn't
the entire country will mobilize around
that person and treat them as a victim
of american racism just to prove that
america's not racist
but why is espn doing like a full story
now about a story that was completely
debunked remember everybody mobilized
you bubba wallace's defense
before they knew that the story wasn't
true and then it turns out the story
wasn't true we'll get some more of this
in just one moment first my sleep
quality matters to me which is why i
have a mattress made just for me by my
friends over at helix sleep helix sleep
has a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i took the helix quiz
i was matched with a particular model it
is a firm model that breathes really
well because i tend to sleep on my
stomach and i warm up at night if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress you match to the
mattress comes directly to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again helix is
awesome you don't need to take my word
for it helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by
both gq and wired magazine helix has
been recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to helix sleep
dot com slash ben take their two minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life if a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix even has financing options
and flexible payment plans a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com ben
that's
helixleep.com
by the way
bubba wallace is not
one of the best drivers in nascar i mean
the amount of publicity that bubba
wallace has gained from this particular
incident is pretty astonishing
according to sportscasting.com
there's a good shot that he is going to
be
voted in to the nascar all-star race via
fan voting
he is not even close to the top in terms
of points earning
right he's he's popular because of
stories like this one but not really
because he's a very good driver
like he's okay but he isn't one of the
best drivers in nascar
he uh he
in 2020
suggested that that
there were stereotypes regarding
nascar's fan base that had to be fought
it's just uh
again here's espn going on with it
of all the turmoil
this is his mom
that was going on in the world
with the black and white the hatred and
everything that was going on
the entire nascar family
rallied behind my son
again over a thing
that didn't happen
all those people who were so silent
on that chat
two weeks earlier
oh i still don't forget
but this moment was still important
um
you know
you can let down your guard a little bit
but
i don't forget the ones that were silent
okay hold up i don't forget the ones
that were silent about a thing that
didn't happen
that's the part where it goes crazy it's
that it's that little tag right there
that's insane
it really is it's crazy
right you go through that whole thing
and it's about how all these people came
together to help bubba wallace in a time
where
again he made an accusation that turned
out not to be true
and
then he's like i don't forget the people
who are silent
again it didn't happen so here's the
question why is espn pushing this
without ever mentioning by the way in
that whole promo
that this thing was not real and the
answer is because the media need a story
about how america is deeply and
systemically racist because if they
don't have that story their entire
narrative about morality falls apart
the the demand for racism exceeds the
supply in the united states at this
point and that is why you have
artificial racist product being made
right this is you want to know why the
jesse smelly
hoax happened it's because he knew there
was a demand for that sort of product
and so he provided demand even if it
meant
creating airsat's racist incidents
if that is america is so not racist
that will it will pay you
and it will make you famous for accusing
somebody of racism without cause
that that that is how non-racist america
is that's how much we hate racism in
this country
it
it's an amazing thing and again this is
endemic throughout sporting coverage
espn has blown out so many fans they've
blown out so many fans because they have
decided their political narrative is so
much more important than just covering
sports i used to be a devotee of espn i
subscribed to espn the magazine i used
to get up at six o'clock in the morning
this is before the days of watching
sports on the internet i used to get up
at six o'clock in the morning every
morning before school so i could watch
all of sportscenter end to end it was
one of my favorite things to do and now
you couldn't pay me to watch espn
because espn has just become woke
central with some bouncing balls
it's just a propaganda center it's like
msnbc except every so often somebody
throws a football nobody wants to watch
that you don't know why the ratings are
in the toilet it's because of that
it's because the only way that nascar
will even make it on espn is in the
context of a story that wasn't true in
the first place
it is it is incredible
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment